[Musik]
halo hat sich willkommen studies welt
heute gibt's eine richtig leckere giotto
tat eine nuss tat und diese startet
ganze mit einem mürbeteig da ist heute
aber nicht ganz normal für mich
[Musik]
ein bisschen abgewandelt mit dem kubus
blüten zucker das und damit das ganze so
ein bisschen wie sag ich da aromatischer
schmeckt genauso ist es sind noch mit
dabei ich zeige euch mal die zutaten
dafür verwendet ihr 50 gramm dattel wir
sind bereits entsteint 30 gramm wasser
50 gramm koks blüten zucker etwas
vanille extrakt 200 gramm kalte butter
350 gramm mehl 1 eigelb etwas salz und
100 gramm gehackte haselnüsse wie
bereits gesagt in steine dachte das ist
ganz wichtig und was sich jetzt zuerst
machen werde ich werde jetzt das wasser
über die daten ließen und die dann
einfach in die mikrowelle stellen damit
die so ein bisschen weich werden ihr
könnt auch die dackel mit kochendem
wasser übergießen dann könnte das mit
der mikrowelle einfach
jetzt sind die das schön weich
und ihr könnt alles eine mixa zu
bereiten falls ihr kein mixa hat
kündigen pürierstab nehmen oder die
daten auch einfach kurz klein hacken das
geht auch und den rest dann einfach mit
den händen verkneten oder mit einem teig
hacker oder mit dem handrührgerät es
gebe es hier oben alle zutaten mal rein
auch vanille extrakt cocos blüten zucker
und damit die butter nicht gleich warm
wird gebe ich erst noch mehr drauf
das eigelb zur bindung
sei es ist immer ganz wichtig und auch
schon mal die hälfte der haselnüsse
die dürfen nämlich mit zerkleinert
werden
jetzt kurz mal eben alles zerkleinern
[Musik]
dann kann ich den teig jetzt hier
aufgeben und noch die restlichen
haselnüsse einknicken
aber alles nur ganz schnell damit der
teig nicht warm wird
[Musik]
das spiel hatte ich auch noch nicht ganz
und jetzt kommt alles hier mit rein
[Musik]
jetzt ist der teig natürlich ein
bisschen warm aber das macht gar nichts
der kompromiss so in den kühlschrank und
dafür gebe ich den jetzt auch im mai
teller am besten bisschen flach drücken
somit schneller kalt und dann für
mindestens eine stunde küren
jetzt ist der website schenk halt und
ihr könnt ihn einmal kurz zusammen
kneten und dann ausräumten ich wollte
jetzt fünf millimeter dick aus ja da ist
schön kalt aber trotzdem richtig
geschmeidig
[Musik]
wenn ich nehme zum ausrollen einfach den
ausbau starb mit diesem 5 millimeter
ring
[Musik]
wenn der teig marktleben sollte könnt
ihr einfach mit einer palette einmal
runter gehen
und dann löst er sich ganz gut
zum backen nehme ich jetzt eine
plattform mit hebe boden so bekomme ich
die tat später nämlich geht raus und die
hat eine echt gute beschichtung muss ich
sagen der teig ist auch eigentlich
fertig genug aber ich hätte das ganze
trotzdem zur sicherheit mit back
tremblay
jetzt kann ich hier den teig auf die
rolle aufnehmen
und vorsichtig reinsetzen
er ist ein bisschen weicher als übliche
beteiligt aber das ist gar nicht schlimm
und wenn es heißt das auch nicht schlimm
dass passend war einfach schön
[Musik]
und bevor ich den teils backe werde ich
ihnen ganz kurz einfrieren oder nochmal
in den kühlschrank stellen damit er noch
mal schön kalt wird und beim backen die
form nicht verliert das geht jetzt ganz
schnell also zehn minuten im gefrierfach
und dann einfach bei 190 grad ober
unterhitze schön verpacken und ich kann
derzeit schon mal die füllung
vorbereiten und aus dem restlichen teig
den könnte zusammenklicken und einfach
keine kekse backen
[Musik]
für die kekse könnt ihr einfach kleine
kugeln formen und dann mit bisschen mehl
bestreuen und mit einem keks stempel
einfach einprägen oder nehmt eine gabel
dann habt ihr ein streifenmuster und
könnte sie dann auch im ofen backen
der mieter ist gebacken die kekse sind
auch gebacken die sind echt richtig
schön und man sieht jetzt schon dass
sich der teig gut raus lösen lässt aber
ich lasse die tat jetzt noch drin
einfach der stabilität wegen damit das
ganze nicht kaputt geht und da kommt
jetzt erst mal eine fruchtige schicht
rein da nehme ich jetzt einfach
aprikosenmarmelade
falls ihr die nicht mögt lass dir sie
einfach weg aber geschmacklich passt
ganz gut dann habe ich diesen feinen
eine kleine frucht trägt und dann kommt
noch eine schotterschicht rein
[Musik]
und dann kam das hier schön rein
und durch das erwärmen kocht er die
marmelade noch so ein bisschen ein und
wenn sie dann wieder abkühlt darauf dann
zieht es schön ein das ist echt immer
ganz gut dass verstreiche ich einfach
kurz mit seinem bug pinsel
dann kommt es jetzt kurz in den
kühlschrank und ich kann so lange die
jobprofil und herstellen
für die jogger creme habe ich mir
gedacht nämlich mascarpone 250 gramm und
120 gramm giotto die habe ich schon
ausgepackt die werden kurz verkleinert
ich glaube das wird meine lieblings
stars
es ist jetzt schon wird ich liebe giotto
sondern führe ich das hier unbekannt das
ganze die mit dem auf der pole verrühren
ich werde mich da immer noch dagegen das
heißt eigentlich kann das ganze mit dem
mascarpone verrühren der mosca vorne
aber ich finde es klingt falsch ich bin
immer noch da für das weben duden
einführen die mascarpone so lala aus
klingt doch falsch der
wie das
ist einfach schwierig der mascarpone
frischkäse
[Musik]
ich finds gut da kommt nämlich noch eine
süße schokoladen schicht habe
und jetzt kommt die creme hier drauf
und wir können zwei zutaten kombiniert
einfach so gut schmecken
[Musik]
die tat kommt jetzt in den kühlschrank
und dann kann ich mich jetzt an die
schokoladen ganache machen die kommt
dann dem jugend drauf und dann wird sie
dekoriert ganz einfach
für die gerne nämlich 100 gramm sahne
und in jeweils 100 gramm zart bitter und
vollmilch kuvertüre
dafür kocht er kurz die sahne aus
das geht ganz schnell
immer eigentlich während des backens
immer in so warte pausen sport macht
dann verbrennt man das was man später zu
sich nimmt
ihr macht einfach score tod
so
nah
dann den herd ausschalten und die
schokolade dazu reden wer möchte kann
jetzt hier zum beispiel noch hassans
likör dazugeben motto schmeckt ja so
genial nach haselnuss aber da könnt ihr
dann den geschmack so ein bisschen noch
intensivieren jetzt einfach nur so lange
rühren bis die schokolade geschmolzen
ist
es gibt ihr diese lauwarme garage direkt
auf die tat
damit sie sich noch gut verteilt
und jetzt wird sie aus dekoriert da für
den job so ich habe basel müsse und zwar
die packen ich habe krebs und ganze
haselnüsse die ganzen die werde ich noch
ein bisschen hacken und dann alles schon
drauf hat
[Musik]
so gefällt sie mir gut und so kommt es
jetzt in den kühlschrank bis zum verzehr
und dann bin ich schon gespannt wie sie
schmecken wird
gestellt
[Musik]
jetzt fertig und darf probiert werden
aber eine
schwarze wolken übergang machen durch
ein video abschluss ohne sarah ich wie
im café ohne job
[Applaus]
mit francesco totti
[Gelächter]
ich hoffe jeder kennt die werbung kommt
leise gerüchteküche
die ich wunderschön hier
die ist echt was die story gesehen hat
von sally heute bisschen knoblauch
blumen
drauf gehört ja weil wir dekorieren
schon gern unsere torten und kuchen metz
blumen und die blumen sind echt stellen
das vom knoblauch den süß aber sie
richtig fette nahm knoblauch übrigens
noch im duden eintragen lassen dieses
leichte gewinne rauch ich habe letztens
mit jemandem diskussion gefecht hier
ist es wert dass die mir dein alter chef
geschenkt hat der mario für mathias
kummer dein knobloch und sehr blöd
wirklich schön
ja aber ich hatte mit jemandem letztens
war es nicht mehr ich glaube schon die
diskussion dass das knobloch gibt und
jeder gesagt es geht es nach david meine
chefin hat zwei es gibt knobloch das
gibt das sex bei ihm gar und wenn es
ihre chefin sagt dann wird so heiser
aber sagen ja es ist möglich weil die
sagt nur dinge die sie kreiert haben sie
nicht irgendwo
laden gesehen ja ich kenne auch eine ich
kannte sogar eine die hieß knoblauch mit
nachnamen und wenn es der name und wenn
der nachname knobloch gibt dann gibt es
um 20 uhr
in meinem buch stets darin mir ist egal
wer trifft zu
das
sieht auf jeden fall sehr schön aus ich
finde auch
[Musik]
der krieg die krise sie will endlich ist
okay komme ich noch eine gabel mein
schatz
210 richtige geduldprobe thurella man
sollte übrigens bevor man die tat an
schneidet den boden darunter wegnehmen
so wie du gerade so wie ich damit man
den tanzboden nicht zerkratzt
ich muss nur noch alles gut
machst du direkt mit krise ich mache die
blüten weg
das meint ihr name noch schmecken nach
knoblauch
okay kommt
hier die spitze
die sprints vorsichtig
das ist so richtig oh mein gott so
richtig crimi
hmm ich
mir gleich die schulter wie die trägen
darin
[Gelächter]
dass wenn dann
ließen die konkurrenz
wie schmeckt in der nähe
magen sorgt
ein kurier gegner nicht achtet sie
darauf geklickt dass es
da aber
die tat ist gut sich sehr lecker in der
tat ja tatsächlich
kommt am sonntag
heute ist frauensache
da schmeckt sie auch
das kriegen ich bin ständig fehler ok
ich würde sagen
die tat ich erprobt
für gut befunden sehr hübsch
einfach so machen und hingucker nicht
einfach ja
und ich habe sogar noch kekse dazu
gemacht also probiert gerne mal auf ich
wünsche euch viel spaß dabei das rezept
gibt es auf
wo gibt's das rezept
war
de und in meiner app
tatsächlich
tatsache tatsache in der tat hat man
schon
statt
das hat mich an mein fehler er kommt nur
birne apfel fällt es ist ja schon nicht
verraten
er hat gegessen hat geht es einfach
wieder
wir machen jetzt tatsächlich muss
hauptsächlich feierabend gibt ja kein
song
feierabend zum gasometer
[Musik]
ist er auf der ok sehr lecker
sie soll aufhören zu essen schützen und
den ganzen google mit ich muss würde es
machen
[Musik]